messenger of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said, "The angels were created from
light, and the jinn were created from
the transparent edge of a fire of a
flame, and Adam was created from that
which was described to you." Meaning, in
the Quran. Now, again, we'll ask this
question, "What do these three creatures
have in common that the Prophet
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions them
together and puts them together? I mean,
there are so many creatures on this
She tells us that the Prophet subhanahu
wa ta'ala said, "The angels were created
from light,
and the jinn or the jinn were created
from the transparent edge of a fire of a
flame,
and Adam was created from that which was
described to you." Meaning, in the
Quran.
Now,
again, we'll ask this question, "What do
these
common
that the Prophet subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions them together and puts them
together? I mean, there are so many
creatures on this earth.
They're created from many different
things,
but
these three creatures, out of all the
others,
why these three creatures mentioned
together?
Because of their free will, right?
What is free will? The option, the
choice
to
do or not,
and to be held accountable
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for the
choices that we make.
Now, we mentioned this before,
and that is that it is
paramount, it is important for us to
understand something about these
creatures
and free will will.
And that is
when we get the answer to the very
important question, "Why is the Prophet
subhanahu wa ta'ala telling us this? Why
is he mentioning these three creatures
together? Why is it necessary for us as
Muslimin in our journey and our path to
Allah and our worship of Allah that we
meet Allah on the day of judgement with
this piece of information. Why?
Very good.
These are the only three creatures in
our existence
and our reality and our
you know, and our dealings on this earth
that will cross paths with each other.
That overlap our destinies, our choices,
they overlap with each other. The angels
interact with the human being, the human
being interacts with the jinn, the jinn
interacts with the angels, the jinn
interacts with the human beings, etc.
And so,
in the science of Usul al-Fiqh,
the scholars tell us that numbers
and the implication of a number is a
type of takhsees.
What that means is when we say for
instance,
"Three creatures have free will." What
does this mean? We understand this to
mean that outside of these three
creatures,
there are no other creatures that have
that free will in the same way.
So for instance,
will there ever be aliens that will come
in contact with the human being and come
and teach us new technologies and
interact with us and breed with us and
take me to your leader and all this
nonsense. Is this ever going to happen?
Absolutely not.
How about
AI?
Will AI ever be sentient
in the sense that it is conscious and it
has free will? Will this ever happen?
Absolutely not.
Will this ever be more intelligent than
the human being?
Listen to the question.
Will AI
ever be more intelligent than the human
being?
The answer is no, definitely.
Why?
Because we have a very simple principle
that it that the Quran teaches us.
The scholars sum up this principle in
saying
faaqidu shay'in laa
yu'tiih.
That you have to possess something first
before you can give it to another.
In order for the human being
to create something more intelligent
than itself, it would have to
it would have to possess
intelligence greater than itself and
then give it to something else.
This is
very
basic logic
that yes, something AI. And we're
speaking about this because we're at a
new AI,
you know, there's people that are
worshipping AI right now. There is a
church that has been built
where people can go there and AI has
taken the form of Isa ibn Maryam.
Alayhis
there and you can go and speak to him
and he'll speak back to you and so
forth.
What's interesting about this church is
the screen of the AI is
you know, this image
of their depiction of Isa
and there's windows facing it.
And you can see it from the inside and
the outside. You can see this screen.
It's visible from the street.
Inside, it looks Isa ibn Maryam.
But outside, because of the way that
they designed the glass and because of
the geometry, it looks like
the
what is referred to in Satanism as the
Baphomet.
It's a creature that is basically a
shapon. It has a human body and the face
of a goat and you know, it has this very
particular image. It's very
it's very important in modern Satanism
and the occult.
Right? Is this accidental? Is this just
Oh, it's just a
it's just a coincidence, right? It's
just a coincidence.
for instance, in movies where
movies and musicians go out of their way
to place satanic symbols in their work.
And then we say, "Well, this is just a
coincidence."
You know how much the average frame
of a Hollywood-produced movie costs to
make? One frame.
Just one frame.
The average frame
of a professional Hollywood movie will
cost anywhere from 20 to 50,000 dollars
each frame.
What do you think? There will be
accidents in these frames with this kind
of money? Some movies
cost upwards of four and five hundred
million dollars to produce.
There's no accidental
,
you know, imagery going on here,
symbolism going on here. It is very
deliberate.
And this is why it's referred to as a
program. This is the
, largest
fourth It's viewed by some as being the
fourth branch of the US government.
And that is the branch of propaganda,
news, etc.
And so, the point here is that a huge
push is being made now
for AI. We have to make AI. We have to
make these data centers. Some of these
data centers
there's one in Utah, for instance, that
is 64 square miles.
It is so big that it has raised the
temperature of the town
by almost 5°.
The entire city's temperature has raised
because of this data center, quote and
quote. Do you think that these are being
made so that you can chit-chat with Jack
chat GPT and say, "Hey, write me a
an email to Sally, right? Tell Sally
that I'll be there for dinner this
evening." Is that why they're making all
of these data centers? This is a huge
ins- infrastructure that is being built.
Hundreds of them are being built across
the country. Why? In order to be able to
store the information of every single
thing you do up to the point where even
your eye movements
from now until the end of your life will
all be documented. More than 50,000 data
points are being saved on every person.
And we say, "What does this have to do
with Islam? What does this have to do
with our religion? There are people who
have started to worship AI. There's
actually this new thing called AI
AI
psychosis, where people are actually
losing their minds
because AI is designed in order to make
you feel the most special guy in
the whole wide world. If you tell AI
an opinion, say, you know what? I think
aliens came to this world and they bred
the human beings a petri petri dish
and
they're going to come back and
collect us. We're a zoo
in, you know, on the earth, which is
actually the ethos of Scientology.
The chat GPT or Grok or they're going to
say, you've cracked the code. You are
genius.
You are an amazing person and here's all
the evidences that support what you have
said.
But they don't want people to know this.
Just that.
And people have started to actually lose
their minds because they think that they
are speaking to a creature of free will.
They think they're speaking to a human
being. Some of them are falling in love.
Falling in love with
a computer program.
To the point that they are even having
weddings and getting married and buying
you know
engagement rings and so forth.
It's a sickness and you can expect that
someone who does not have the Quran,
does not have the Sunnah,
anyone can take them and mislead them.
But, this doesn't mean that the Muslimin
are
immune to these diseases. You live
amongst a people, you will start to take
up their traits traits. And this is why
the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said about living
with or amongst the
non-Muslims, he said, "La tata ra'a
naruhuma."
That the Muslim should never live close
enough to be able to see the lit fire of
the non-Muslim community. Not meaning
that a person doesn't deal with them and
import and export and so forth, exchange
knowledge, exchange experience.
But, when a person lives in and amongst
a people, they will start to be a
product of that
of that environment.
And so, I, you know, I wish I could tell
you how many people, couples, Muslims
Muslim husband and wives come to me and
say, "Whenever we have a dispute, we
consult ChatGPT.
And they are the ultimate judge. It is
the ultimate judge in our disputes.
Or, you know, I I I discuss with
ChatGPT on how to be a good husband or
how to be a good wife." As if the Quran
doesn't exist.
As if the Quran doesn't have any answers
in it.
As if the Quran is inaccessible to the
average person.
I have had ChatGPT
produce for me entire chapters
that do not exist in books.
I'll say
you know, word the word the question
in a very specific way. Tell me about
the chapter of this book that says 1 2 3
and it will produce for me an entire
chapter that doesn't exist in that book.
And they have certain
they have made some programs that are
specialized in giving fatwa.
Specialized AI programs that are giving
fatawa.
And there are some of them that when you
ask a particular question, it has been
designed to pick up on what it is you
would to hear
and it is tailored to feed you what it
thinks you want to hear.
So, if you want to hear that there is no
God, it will give you all the evidences
and tell you how
brilliant you are and how unique you
are. And it of all the human beings that
it's ever interacted with, it has
learned the most from you. You are truly
gifted. Humanity has been misguided up
until this moment where it has
discovered you. Your country and your
people need you, right? And so forth.
And people are getting sick.
One of the most dangerous things you
could do is give programs this to
your children, to allow your children to
interact with these things
because they are very susceptible to the
discussions that are going on.
Right now we have, you know,
disclosures of aliens and oh, the US
government's known about aliens for
you know, almost 100 years, but
they've been keeping keeping it under
wraps, but now they're they're coming
clean that really there were aliens that
came and visited us and dropped off some
technology and interacted with us or
that AI is sentient and it can think and
speak and we need to have rights, a bill
of rights. Some have even proposed that
AI be included in the Bill of Rights,
the US Constitution.
Right?
And on top of that, while we are all
distracted with this,
in the past couple months, a bill has
been passed to merge the militaries of
Israel and US military into one. The
Israeli military will now be a part of
every single branch of the US military.
Every single one.
Every single one, all the way up to the
top. Why? Why would you merge a foreign
country's
military
with the United States military?
Because they are two sides of the same
coin.
And this is an international thing.
And so we have to be extremely vigilant.
Believe nothing that you hear and only
believe half of what you see.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Now I feel this one is
the shakes out of business.
[Arabic recitation]
you'll have AI give the football.
farm
a farm
[Arabic recitation]
it been?
I know. Look at that. I got my eye on
you.
[Arabic recitation]
You know, you work hard now.
I'm saying I know you'll be
Yeah. Better find
[Silence]
Yeah, I see him. I'm I'm counting on
about 6 months.
[Arabic recitation]
you'll be good.
[Silence]
This is good now, I think.
But it needs to be a little bit better.
What this is